mass protests are going on in New Delhi
and elsewhere in India against a
citizenship law that opponents see as
anti-muslim there have been more
violence in the northern city of Lucknow
where officers have been hitting people
with sticks after a police station has
damaged three protesters were killed on
Thursday and hundreds detained the new
legislation offers a path to citizenship
for persecuted minorities from three
neighboring countries but it excludes
Muslims Sabinas Resta is in New Delhi
that's where we go to her now
tell us what's happening around you and
where the protests are also taking place
elsewhere so right now I'm in jammy
University where there is a huge crowd
since the morning the crowds have really
swollen and there are like hundreds of
people around here it's it keeps on
growing and a lot of people are over
here are chanting for freedom chanting
for the Constitution and they're
chanting to end this new law so from
from what we've been hearing across the
country in in Delhi at least there have
been massive protests in other parts of
Delhi as well and across the country the
government has tried to suppress it
what's that
so what's been also interesting is like
a lot of the violence that has happened
across the country it's been in BJP rule
states so the people who have died
including in Lucknow has also been BJP
curfew is in the mic the city of
Mangalore there is internet that's been
disturbed in different places across the
country but most people over here are
saying that this is more than just a
demonstration and a protest against the
Constitution law and it's going to keep
going and with the protest continuing
and the numbers we're seeing on the
streets you've been finding that women
are particularly playing an active part
here
[Music]
yeah so what we've seen not only here
but all over like we were in a leaker
earlier where we saw a large number of
women who came out to protest and it's
quite opposite of what a lot of people
have been saying about women not coming
forth in this protest so especially in a
league where there was a lot of fear
amongst the men after the brutal
crackdown in amu and to support them
mothers sisters and all local women
Muslim women along with Hindu women came
in support